how about some MVP odds and then a few
props based on the MVP odds this comes
from FanDuel Patrick mahomes the
favourite to win the regular season MVP
at plus 380 that means bet 100 win $380
Lamar Jackson last years MVP even with
Russell Wilson at plus 600 a little bit
of a surprise because Russell Wilson has
never gotten a single MVP vote in his
entire NFL career Lamar Jackson got all
of them last season they have the same
odds I'm surprised by dak Prescott at
plus 1200 Drew Brees I'm surprised is as
high as he is as well at plus 1,600 and
you see the list they're finishing with
Aaron Rodgers at plus 2300 which one big
cat stands out to you as the juiciest of
the MVP picks
how about Aaron Rodgers with all the new
weapons that the Packers guy you know
Holmes is obviously even though it's the
it's the lowest odds or the highest odds
he would be the one that I would put my
money on at plus 350 I think it was but
Tom Brady who'd be interesting there
because the MVP a lot of times is you
know it's stats but it's also storyline
and Tom Brady is gonna be everyone's
gonna be watching the Fox and everyone's
gonna be seeing what happens there and
guess what he has a lot of weapons and
Bruce Arians is going to let him throw
the ball and let him score points so I
would say plus 1800 he would probably be
the juiciest odds well to me the the
most intriguing potential bet and we
didn't even see him on the screen I
don't know where he is on the fan duel
on it Skyler Murray because we have seen
the last two years a second-year
quarterback take the NFL by storm
wire-to-wire and win the MVP
it was mahomes in 2018 it was Lamar
Jackson in 2019 and I think very well
could be Kyler Murray a plus 2600
underdog to win it all I would put my
money on Murray and another one here's
another one here's another one if we're
talking about second year guys who take
the NFL by storm and and this really is
a roll of the dice long shot but I'm a
big drew lock guy and when you consider
the weapons non sarcastically that the
Broncos have added for him between
Melvin Gordon the draft picks they used
on guys like Jerry Judy
in the first round and more receiving
help and they've got the tight ends and
they still have Courtland Sutton
I think Drew lock could could be a guy
who gets plenty of attention this year
the Broncos gonna have to be a lot
better than they've been the past few
seasons but Drew Lock is one that
intrigues me and he's not on the list
either I assume he's like up around
+4000 or more that's a good one another
one that we'll throw out there that's
not on the list
I'm still believer in Sam journals I
really am I'm still believer in Sam
Donald and he gets the reset button on
this year you know they've put a couple
offensive linemen in front of him so it
would be very tough but but his odds
probably reflect that and if you're
looking for a real long shot he would
probably be the one I look at all right
to the extent that FanDuel or anyone
else would be setting odds on this Prop
give me your answer who plays for
another team first Seahawks quarterback
Russell Wilson or Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers who will be meeting with
reporters for the first time since the
Packers 2020 draft later today where's
he meeting with them virtually you can I
get the link to that I'll see what I can
do to hook you up I haven't gotten a
link for some reason for some reason I'm
not invited okay Aaron Rodgers played
for the another team first yeah he
seemed they just drafted his backup in
the first round so maybe it's not next
year maybe it's not the year after that
but I if you think Russell Wilson's
gonna gonna be a Seahawk for the rest of
his career it's got to be Aaron Rodgers
yeah you know I agree with you and even
though the cap hit next year would be
significant for the Packers of trade
Aaron Rodgers the cap hit for keeping
him would be even higher by like 4.7
million and they'd avoid 22 million in
cash and he may want to move on after
this season he met regardless of what he
says today and you know he's always very
calculated he's always very tactical and
the things he says and doesn't say but
yeah I'm gonna be parsing out his words
very carefully to see what the messages
really are and whether he's going to
want to be there after this season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports